mon sentiment c'est bien ce style que
son traditionnel noir ecstasy donc
puisque le mc alger
nous aimerions quelque part à gérer un
petit retour d'expérience hommes sur le
terrain
ou bien les idées j'ai commencé ma
carrière quand vous ingénieurs régulière
dans ma tête et mon premier d'endroits
où j'ai travaillé à chaque fois très
humide et je vais partager ni les armes
j'ai vécu une sorte que de frustration
et je n'ai pas compris que qu'est ce que
c'est que l'interaction humaine en fait
est différent entre programmé un
ordinateur les programmes l humain mais
ils sont aussi la seule différence c'est
que l'ordinateur la vague d'émotion il
n'a pas d'ego alors que l'humain si il à
aller nous les ingénieurs dans la
tendance à se délester de cet art
inhumaines de la chose qu'on peut
partager une idée commence à dire voilà
ces terrains
se nourrir peut pas s qui pourront
prendre c'est que l'environnement de
travail
il ya quelque chose qui s'appelle la
dynamique collective
cette dynamique collective est très
simple on doit se mettre à la place de
la personne à qui on propose unis on
doit se mettre à la place de la personne
que l'idée a impacté au quotidien
comment il voit la main
est-ce qu'elle va le lire assidûment
est ce que donnera lui donner un sourire
gourmand si on comprend pas cet aspect
c'est très difficile pour nous de
convaincre à 200 il ya des exemples que
je peux partager avec vous ce atteignant
3 aux incantations et cette passion
beaucoup de mes amis la regarde comme
une folie on m'appelle fou parce que je
suis la personne qui le matériel et
moral qui veut dématérialisée noté qu'
en train de balancer des termes comme
une application monde
six mois qui s'appelle abubakar et j'en
vois qu'il ya cinq ans je peux
comprendre pourquoi ça a été mais
j'étais convaincu d'une chose que si ce
changement on devait arriver c'est qu'il
devait bénéficier
beaucoup de personnes m'ont dit que au
début on repart de matérialiser la crème
à nos bras parce que ça tue une souris
économie où les gens tous quelque chose
donc ils vont de l'autre c'est vrai que
c'est arrivé parce que toute idée de
changement vient aussi de la réalité des
choses
on peut choisir à d'ignorer cette
réalité où on peut accepter cette
réalité et composer avec
en fait le maïs est que mon équipe avait
adopté avec moi c'est que à chaque
problème on va regarder cinq premiers
mais on m'a regardé 5 autrui alors c'est
quoi les problèmes d'une
dématérialisation aucun changement est
ce que malheureusement aucun peut
concevoir ne pas avoir une manne à
quelqu'un le plus bas ce pays avait dit
qu'il est nous parce que tu es investi
beaucoup d'argent il veut comprendre
dans quelque chose qu'elle a un jour
disparaître à dix réalisations signature
mais est-ce qu'ils n'avaient pas compris
c'est que c'était pas mon cas c'était
pas mon but
mon but c'était la société avoir encore
un problème qui s'appelle
on se sert à ce problème il est un
handicap
et c'est pas moi qui le dit moi j'ai
juste d'observer ya un rapport de la
banque mondiale qui dit la même chose
qu'en tant que notre société souffre de
confiance en elle
le problème s'aggrave d'année en année
que maintenant le problème s'approfondit
à ce gros sein de la société marocaine
nommée au sein des familles marocaines
on arrivera à se faire confiance l'idée
est que comment on peut adopter de
digital pour améliorer cette confiance
sociétal le fait que personnellement
j'ai vécu dix ans aux états unis
j'ai légaliser ma signature de poids sur
des hommes franchiront formaroc exploit
l'année de légaliser la châtre vie si je
suis une démission un contrat de travail
un contrat de loyer d'importants
contrats même élevé une assemblée
générale voir
et pourquoi pas ce que l'on se fait pas
confiance c'est malheureux donc on a
deux jours soit on attend la nouvelle
génération à mediaset confiance soir
adapté des outils pragmatiques pour le
faire
comment une application augmente des
professionnels
je voudrais rendre aujourd'hui quand
quelqu'un a besoin d'une femme de ménage
qu'est ce qu'il fait dans une société
marocaine qui prend téléphone et il
appelle quelqu'un en qui il a confiance
pour recommander une personne
ok donc notre société travaille la base
de confiance mais en même temps on
n'arrive pas à ce qu'on fait
comment un outil peut améliorer
cependant tout entendu des histoires de
personnes qui se sont fait agresser sur
à vitteaux par exemple si je peux vendre
un pc portable quelqu'un débat va
m'agresser est parti
comment je veux avoir une passion et
visiteurs présents l idée est simple il
faut composer avec notre manière de
faire pour qu'on a commencé par nos
qatar parce que c'est le début de la
barrasse c'est la paperasse monde
comment on va les utiliser mon radar est
ce que n'est pas un gros budget pour
simplement d'abord les palmiers et
deuxièmement si les parts de cette
budget la dématérialisation badass
serait pas la priorité
donc on doit répondre à ça vous auquel
ils prennent aujourd'hui une plateforme
mis en face à la crise un an google ce
que je partage avec vous c'est le jus de
cinq ans de travail et qu'il fallait pas
commencer par dire voilà on va mettre
des machines et en l'accusant interagir
avec nîmes sans changer en disant voilà
les humains vont rester sur place
maintenant c'est juste qu'ils vont pas
voir ce citoyen ils vont traiter sa
demande à distance la demande se fait
entièrement d'une manière biométrique à
travers selphy signature des documents
photos et l'agent devra signer
électroniquement la mécanisation pour
que le citoyen d'un prime chez soi
l'interaction existe trouve maintenant
les digital et c'est le système qui
coûte cher qui c'est qui va le payer
c'est simple aujourd'hui c'est un
service à valeur ajoutée le citoyen qui
n'a pas d'argent pour qu'il veut pas
renvoyer à se dépasser et d'utiliser le
système gratuit dont celui qui veut pas
se laisser dépasser
payez moins de dirhams pour le faire
maintenant à partir de ces idées roms
ont valu l'agent qui traitement comme ça
ne va pas
oui un équilibre un certificat de
résidence sans devoir citoyen va toucher
un pourcentage de ses neuf dix
rencontres le citoyen d'un pays
ok et là on rentre dans un modèle
inclusif et la prochaine venue parce que
on l'avouera critiqué par des mules à le
traiter de corrompus et la réalité là
sont quand même fait partie de notre
système
notre culture c'est un élément important
de l'appareil sécuritaire saignements
importants de l'administration marocaine
il est mal pris c'est la réalité
l'état va jamais amélioré sa condition à
travers une nouvelle relation
on peut faire ça à travers une approche
sociétale et inclusive on peut faire ça
donc l'idée c'est ça c'est un chaque
continent problème on le réserve
pourquoi nous devons à la patronne est
ce qu'on va par le fait dans les appels
d'offres et dans la préparation du
budget la ministre a encore réuni entre
balma la fraude aujourd'hui si on amène
à nous mesurer l'impact de la fraude se
voir société on peut pas ce qui à la
demande donc comment ruiner la france
c'est simple aujourd'hui si je vous
ramène un certificat pour un cocon
qu'acheter vous n'avez aucun moyen de
vendre
il vient mais si je vous imprime un qr
code que j'ai imprimé chez moi sur le
document dont le scanner en trois
secondes aux deux roses
vous allez avoir loupé des documents et
voir l'organisation à ta mère voit notre
problème quand même donc nous n'arrivons
tissier 38 problème dans la société
comprend les jeux les deux exemples
avant de terminer nous avons maroc
un million de personnes qui ne
travaillent pas deux qui sont pas formés
pour éduquer ces personnes là sont ce
qu'on appelle des mails ou g us de
novembre
cette personne travaille avec la
confiance aussi
ambri nuisit gardien fokker femmes
d'énergie comme un besoin de faire ces
deux choses d éduquer société man en
leur donnant un outil qui leur fait
comprendre qu'il faut travailler
sérieusement parce que je suis mené et
surtout il faut améliorer le volume de
transactions c'est à dire qu'au lieu que
moi je mange le plan comprenait que
quelqu'un connait je vais me référer à
l'application qui est activée sous
bulgarie et à travers la commune
quand je dépose de l'e mail destra quand
je dépose ma signature pour le plaisir à
l'administration box un accès gratuit
pour cette personne de faire la même
chose et je peux faire du régime c'est à
dire en quelques années une prestation
une femme de ménage dans le gardien je
peux faire ce régime là et c'est pas
comme une part nouvelle n'importe qui
peut faire pleurer tina personnes
rémunérées 5 star et ainsi de suite
mais là je peux reprocher n'importe qui
que je connais pas et je vais me faire
confiance je peux faire base avec une
personne rivaux n'est pas donc la
constance et s'écrit écrit un lien
digitale de confiance consommation
comment on peut aider les colonies à
travers le micro finance aujourd'hui si
je veux un petit cri de dirhams qui le
feront un dossier comme ça et tout une
commission qui va se réunir pour décider
si neri deux d'entre eux lundi midi
ramon l'idée ce que provoquer un nouveau
devient une plateforme nationale de
facturation où je reçois toutes mes
factures télécoms lillers 32 voitures
broyées jurés ne soit sur 24 ans et je
les paye sur la quatre ans pourquoi
parce que quand j'avais besoin son
patron celui qui m'a envoyé la facture a
investi ses vieux lévis c'est à dire
qu'il connaît la seconde
visage ma facture est comme moi je paie
ses factures en capture de valables dans
trois ans quand j'ai besoin d'un petit
crédit il ya plus besoin de dossiers de
collisions
il ya un screen il ya un an d'amour elle
critique qui dit que cette personne est
le seul round
elle reste elle est financièrement
responsable est l'instrument de tel et
tel parce que je connais sont
historiques les pays bas 3 1 c'est ce
qui se fait ailleurs
c'est juste que l'approché des
différentes manoeuvres et en dames a
raté le barman marco
si au début on aurait dit à ses
destinées aux emmys les écouter
le tandem le match dans votre approche
de marque sera là l'autre match ça
n'aurait pas marché
donc quand on change ça traîne a créé un
grand impact sur la société
il faut y aller doucement surnom mais
surtout identifié l'intérêt de chacun
c'est difficile de faire mener un groupe
de personnes dans la même direction
quand on est seul on m'a dit secours
mais quand vous tombez pas les noirs
il faut y aller avec les autres donc
convaincre ces personnes le projet
wehrlin et prend du temps c'est un
investissement à faire simple ces
légumes catch on peut garder au style
d'ingénieurs cd style technique mais les
softs qui use ça c'est très important
malheureusement de nos enseignements les
solstices cci qu'une minorité religieuse
parfois on doit apprendre sur le permis
mais ce serait bien de se retrancher sur
ça et se rappeler qu'on est tous humains
convenir à notre île et les teams bol
c'est vraiment avoir un maroc
socialement responsable et
technologiquement avance merci
[Applaudissements]